talk to me about your relationship with
alcohol and how it's changed I pretty
much barely drink anymore I used to
drink numerous times per week there was
always at least one extremely heavy
Blowout at the weekend what is going on
here when you're having 15 or 20 drinks
a week you're pretty much constantly in
a state of being either drunk or
hungover if you really like alcohol it
does two things to you it makes you more
extroverted and enthusiastic and more
full of positive emotion and the second
thing it does is reduce anxiety alcohol
targets mitochondria alcohol poisoning
is due to mitochondrial disruption and
impairment there were times I was like
man I could never be a sober person it
was just alcohol for me always if you
took something fun alcohol made it more
fun and if you took something boring it
made it less boring right now as we
speak at least one in 10 Americans meets
the criteria for either alcohol abuse or
alcohol dependence which we now call
alcohol use disorder the alcohol is it's
hell of a it's a hell of a drug man